no no that's what you're doing right you
have to do it wrong and I thought that's
kind of weird to have an Indian woman on
my background don't do that I try to
avoid that
what's up believe nation over the past
few months I have been more dedicated to
building my Instagram account and as a
result I've spent a lot more time on my
phone and gotten these weird pains
happen in my neck coming home and having
to crack it multiple times and so this
weekend I decided that I would learn how
to position myself better so that I
don't get neck pain anymore and so in
this video Nina and I are gonna share
with you five different positions that
you can use five five five so you don't
get neck pains anymore using your cell
phone either
[Music]
now before getting started understand
that your head the average head is ten
to eleven pounds that's a lot of
pressure put up on your neck but if you
are in the position of 45 degrees in a
demo 45 degrees if that's how you are
doing your phone like most people that's
a 45 degree angle you've got 50 pounds
if your head is 10 to 11 pounds that
means you've got 50 extra pounds of
pressure on your shoulders and it's no
wonder why you've got neck pain so let's
show you how to fix it okay first
position while standing is the hug
yourself so take one arm cross it across
yeah and then the other arm you take
your elbow and rest it on your nina
showing some guns rest it on your arm
yeah and the goal here is we want to get
the phone to bi-level and so the arm can
get tired easily but when you rest it
against the other hand it's a lot easier
so you hug yourself and then you can
more easily get that phone up to eye
level
[Music]
okay standing position number two is a
double V now the hug yourself position
is great at the beginning but you may
still get tired and you may and you may
also need both your hands to be able to
to text with so the double V you bring
both arms in and the elbow is in against
you the side of your body so you have a
little bit of relaxation there where
you're you're leaning in and you're not
just fully supporting your arms again
we're bringing in the phone up so that
it's pretty much at eye level and you're
reducing the pressure of the weight of
your head on your neck now this is much
better than just having your arms up and
out because if you're doing it like that
or even with both your hands they will
get tired those arms will get tired and
so instead of slouching over bring the
arms in with the elbows in against your
body so that it's easier to keep that
position for as long as possible
[Music]
all right standing position number three
is the double chin not the sexiest of
all of our potential options here but if
your hands are getting tired because you
are standing and texting for too long
what I want you to avoid is our usual
position so if Nina turns to the side
you'll see what normally people do
they're leaning over your hunche don't
do that try to avoid that if you can't
do one of our first two positions then
bring the phone where is normal and
comfortable for you and then just bring
your chin back a little bit and look
down so what we want to avoid is that
massive hunch we want our shoulders back
not forward we want our neck in a normal
position not too forward
so you're still able to use your phone
not work too hard on straining your arm
muscles here they're tired because of
the first two positions but we're still
able to get a lot of work done without
us having to put massive strain on our
neck
[Music]
okay position number four is the elbow
knee so this is what we do when we're
sitting down often when we're sitting
down we are slouched again our shoulders
are over massive 45-degree angle fifty
pounds of pressure happening on your
shoulders and on your neck we do not
want that so what we want to do is take
both of our elbows and put them on our
knees try to keep your back as straight
as possible and then a little bit of a
look down the idea is we're bringing the
phone almost up to our eye level and
it's gonna save you a lot of pressure on
your neck and our last position is
elbows on the table if you are relaxing
at home or if you're at a busy work day
and you need to do a lot of cell phone
usage while sitting down if you have a
table in front of you
yeah don't slouch don't roll those
shoulders forward try to sit up straight
put your big cushion is falling put your
elbows on the table and again look the
phone is almost at eye level the
shoulders are back the neck is pretty
straight just doing this will save your
neck tons of pressure
[Music]
now I've got a final bonus tip for you
as well all of this may make sense maybe
awesome say yes I'm gonna try this I
want to save my neck but how do we make
sure that we actually follow through on
it one of the best hacks that I found is
change the background of your cell phone
change the login screen and change the
background at first I did it up some
Indian woman because she was the one
that I learned some of these techniques
from and then I thought that's kind of
weird to have an Indian woman on my
background so I thought okay Nina we're
gonna take a picture of you doing the
proper pose
so that when I log on and I turn my
phone on every day every time multiple
times per day I guess I'm saying Nina in
the pose and it reminds me it's a quick
check because I will often by default do
the old habits I see in this picture and
then boom up straight doing it properly
now if you guys have any extra hacks
that you want to share let me know leave
it down in the comments below also if
you want to learn how to separate the
egg yolk from the egg white with a
simple water bottle check out the video
next to me I think you're gonna enjoy we
believe in you and we'll see you there
today I'm going to show you the easiest
way to separate the yolk from the white